so uh jumping on in uh you know that i'm
a fan of your work um and i think more
people need to be fans of your work if
someone has not seen anything that
you've done before what is the first
thing that they should watch and why
um
that's so hard i mean honestly the work
i'm proudest of is my theater work uh
which is it sounds horribly pretentious
to say that but uh obviously they can't
go back and see it so uh
i don't know i mean
i think midnight in paris is a pretty
perfect
movie
and uh that that role was was such a joy
to play i think
you know i think house of cards
um
that arc
was one of the more
fulfilling and and and complete and
satisfying arcs of a character that i've
that i've played on camera
uh when did you realize that um a lot of
people watch billions
[Laughter]
uh
i think i was i was
on the new jersey turnpike or it was
somewhere where they still had a
toll booth collector
who uh
he wouldn't give me my change
because he just wanted to you know he's
like oh my god it's mike prince
um
so
uh
i'm i'm friendly with frank grillo and
he told me that he was
just shocked at how many he is a small
character and he was shocked at how many
people watched the show and stopped to
talk to him about it um and i guess
you've maybe experienced the same
yeah yeah definitely it has a it has a
a large and i think
very
passionate uh viewership and it's also
incredible you know they have all these
um
cameos these
you know billionaires and
uh athletes and musicians and
um
who who come on set and it's really kind
of fun to see these incredibly
accomplished
and
powerful people in their own right turn
into little fanboys and girls uh when
they come to sad and say oh my god
that's
you know
that's that's the office that's
um you know oh that's a backdrop i
thought it was a set and you know they
they get giddy and that's kind of fun to
see
jumping into why i get to talk to you
what is it actually how did you get cast
in the movie was it
um and what is it like meeting steven
spielberg for the first time
you know it's so familiar
he is
he's so warm and welcoming and outer
directed and curious
and he's just excited to
[Music]
um to communicate with his new
collaborators um
the first time he i when he when i was
offered the role he called me
um
and uh so i spoke to him for a while
about the character and and
and
and the project and how he wants to do
it his and i got a sense of his
incredible
enthusiasm for the project um
but yeah he
he is
you know
i grew up
with his movies and and
um
i was amazed how often on set we just
had to be talking with
a jet or a shark
about you know some
referencing some movie and we'd be like
oh right that was that's a steven
spielberg movie i was like sorry i was
just referencing jurassic park i was
just referencing
close encounters or there's a lost ark
[Music]
so much of what we think of as
storytelling
uh now
comes from him
um
and or at least his
framing of of um these these
storytelling techniques because
you know a lot of it comes from
hitchcock or you know he he is himself a
cauldron of
film references
um
but
uh it was
it sort of dawned on you
as you're working with him that
this is that same guy who who made that
movie
that
you know
that broke your heart and
scared you and then made you cheer um so
it was it was really fun
were you
happy or relieved that you did not have
to do the singing and dancing like
everyone else
[Laughter]
[Music]
you didn't give me the option that i was
i was i was i was upset and sad that
sure we can also work that in
that is not that was not one of the
options uh that is not what happened i i
you know
it was not there's no
there's no world in which
people want to pay 15 to watch me sing
and dance so
um
i think it was better for all parties
involved
oh i listen i saw the film last night
and there's so many things that struck
me about it but it just felt so
immersive when i was watching and i
can't imagine what it was like when you
stepped on set for the first time and
saw the level of detail on everything so
could you sort of talk about maybe that
that first time you stepped on set
yeah um
i think the first
the first dance set was uh was a
location you know the end of that first
rumble
uh you know when i go and i break up the
fight and um
uh
it was it was so cool i mean you know it
wasn't a set it was
this abandoned lot uh in uh in harlem
and
um
[Music]
you just you you you show up and you're
like this is a steven spielberg movie i
don't know
how you know it it's just a bunch of
rocks you know there's a bunch of you
know broken
bottles and and
spray paint on the walls but there's a
there was a there's a painterliness
there's
a uh
harmony to to
to to the and a level of artistry to to
everything
um
that you just sort of know
you're in good hands
um
and
and it felt it felt old school you know
we were shooting in
the
middle of summer
brutally hot days and
you know the brighter the sun gets the
brighter the lights have to get to
you know to to to knock down those
shadows
and so
janusz kaminsky had these massive
old-school
lights that
were
speaking of another
spielberg reference i had that
sunburn on half my face like in close
encounters
because the light it was just right
there and it was it was literally
burning us um so it was a it's a very
visceral
um
there's not much down time on a on a
spielberg set i've learned um
it's it it's very fast-paced
um
and
you know as soon as you get one shot
you're right on to the next
um
it's it's it's athletic
uh
in in its execution
yeah i can't i've never been on a
spielberg set i can't imagine uh what
it's like so you didn't does he do a lot
of coverage or was it pretty much
no that's that's i mean that's that's
the joy of working with
somebody who is so experienced and so
confident
and
uh
so in tune with his collaborators um
you know he's clearly
incredibly prepared when he shows up
uh on set every day but you really
you really get the sense that he doesn't
know how he's going to shoot it till he
gets there
and
[Music]
that is i think his
his his genius his shot making
um the the that
where to put the camera how to move it
in order to tell the story is his native
language
and
he
he places the camera in a way that i've
never seen any director
so that was really really exciting but
it in it it
it's challenging it's it's it's hard
work because
you've got this
dense script
and
so many moving parts in the camera
starting off in a wide and moving into a
two shot and then like this extreme
close-up and then back out into a wide
all in one shot and he's all working it
out and you have to hit your marks and
and get the timing right but there's a
level of focus on the set that that
makes that doable whereas i think if you
were trying to do it on another set it
would just be too much
but everybody is
his focus and and in tune and it's
really it's fun i also think everyone on
a spielberg set is not messing around
everyone is you know i'm sure mentally
in the space and not looking at their
phones etc
yeah exactly it's really it's a joy to
and and i think this movie in particular
with so many
you know a lot of people who didn't have
much film experience
um
but
were
aware of how special the experience was
at every moment and didn't want to
didn't want to have didn't want to miss
a good day on set so everybody everybody
brought their game definitely
i got to stop there i'm just going to
say congrats i wish you nothing but the
best and great talking with you again
thanks good to see you